JAMES MCLURKIN: So the whole
point of the AIY Projects team
at Google is to build artificial
intelligence kits that
let makers take the cool
parts of Google intelligence
and put them into their builds.
Last year, we released
the Voice Kit--
train, fast-- which was a kit
that lets you record your voice
and then analyze it and get the
text back from what you said.
This year we're
releasing the Vision Kit.
It does not need an
internet connection.
It does not need the cloud.
You program it with the
Neural Network model,
and the kit then gives you
back data on what it sees.
So if I give it a face,
the light will come on.
And then as I get
happier, the light
will change from blue to yellow.
So this is our mobile
nets neural network.
This is an object classifier.
And it's got 1,000 different
common objects in it.
We have a banana.
And let's see, a screwdriver.
Yeah, it's got that pretty good.
It's got an apple.
Not just an apple--
it's got the type
of apple as well.
And even a water
bottle, which is tricky
because there's a clear thing.
So it's not really a thing.
It's just reflecting
other things.
So learning how to
use these things
and how to make it detect
what you want to detect
is going to be part of the fun.
Our face detector
code told us not only
that there is a
face in the image,
but it also tells us
where the face is.
It gives us the
geometry of the face.
So we can use that to
build a tracker that
can follow me wherever I go.
We've shown you face
detection, object recognition,
and face tracking with
the Google AIY Vision Kit.
But this is just beginning.
Click on the link
below to learn more.
We're really looking
forward to seeing
what you build with this kit.
[MUSIC PLAYING]